Ryan, look at these pullovers.
Don't they look nice?
Yes.
But I don't like V-necks very much.
I find them a little too casual.
Well, there are other styles too.
Look!
What's your favorite color?
I like all colors except navy blue.
Actually, I really hate navy blue...
...because it reminds me too much of my old school uniform.
How about suits?
Is there a color that you don't like at all?
Well, I don't really like light-colored suits.
You're right.
Light colors are no longer fashionable.
Are white shirts too traditional for you?
Not at all.
Actually, I prefer a suit and tie for important occasions.
Well then, why don't you buy a white shirt and a brightly colored tie?
It's the perfect outfit to create a good impression.